こんしゅうのざっくばらん
日本出張
せんしゅうから日本に来ています。
いつものように、講演、シンギュラリティ・ソサエティのイベント、Youtube撮影等です。
平均して１日あたり３個程度の予定が入るとパソコンの前に座っている時間がほとんどないので、かいはつは進まないし、メルマガを書く時間を見つけるのも大変です。
そんな中で、楽しみにしているのが食事です。
豪華で時間がかかる食事よりも、手頃な価格のB級グルメを楽しんでいる私です。
値上がりしたとは言え、下の写真のような健康的で美味しいランチが1500円以下で食べられる日本は、私のように米国から来た人間にとっては天国のような場所です。
1500円は今の相場だと10ドル以下、それも税とサービス料込みです。
米国だと25ドル（4000円）払ってもこの満足感は得られません。
Cybercab
9月3日に、Teslaのロボタクシー・サービス「Cybercab」が、テキサス州オースチンで正式にスタートしました。
TeslaがさいしょにCybercabのコンセプト・モデルを披露したのは、2024年10月でしたが、わずか2年で商用サービスを開始しました。
特筆すべきなのは、FSD（自動運転技術）の進化のスピードです。
Waymoが最初からレベル４（運転手なしの自動運転）を目指していたのに対して、Teslaはレベル２（高度運転補助）からスタートしており、2年前の時点でも、運転手の監視が必要なレベル２止まりでした。
そこからわずか2年で、レベル４での商用サービスにまで持っていくことができた点は高く評価して良いと思います。
私自身も、毎日のようにTesla車でFSDを活用していますが、ここ2年ほどのFSDの進化はめざましく、「私自身が運転するよりも安全」と、今でははっきりと言えるようになりました。
他の都市への拡張はこれからだと思いますが、すでにオースチンの街中にはCybercabが溢れており、そんな様子が他の都市にまで広がるのは時間の問題でしかないと思います。
実際に走っている様子や乗った人たちの感想を知るには、下のYouTubeを見るのが一番良いと思います。
[EN]The Future Has Arrived | Cybercab[/EN]
[EN]I Made a Bet with Tesla[/EN]
[EN]I Rode in Tesla’s Cybercab… It Changed My Mind[/EN]
[EN]I Rode in Tesla’s Cybercab - I Wasn’t Ready for This[/EN]
ただし、ロボタクシー・ビジネスを一気にスケールさせるには、駐車場、充電、清掃などの設備がボトルネックになります。
オースチンには約150基のスーパーチャージャーがありますが、それで運営できるのは高々1,000台だという
があり、それ以上の規模にするには大きなせつびとうしが必要です。
そこで注目されているのが、Cybercab（ハンドル・アクセル・ブレーキ等の操作系の装置を一切持たない自動運転専用モデル）を一般ユーザーに販売し、使っていない時間帯にTeslaのネットワークに貸し出してもらうというビジネスモデルです。
Teslaは売上の35パーセントとFSDの月額$99を受け取り、巨額のせつびとうしを避けながら台数を増やせます。
Cern Basher氏は、$30,000のCybercabを買った個人の利回りは、稼働率30〜65パーセントという保守的な前提でも年30パーセントから100パーセント超になると試算しています。
良いアイデアだとは思いますが、Teslaのオーナーとして、まずさいしょに実現して欲しいのは空港までの送迎です。
出発の際には「家に帰れ」と指示を出せば自動運転で帰り、到着する際には空港まで迎えに来てくれる、それだけでも月額$99を払う価値があります。
ハーネスは「馬具」をイメージすると理解しやすい
最近、エーアイ に関する議論で「ハーネス」という言葉を良く目にするようになりました。
私自身もしばしば使います。
ハーネスとは、大規模言語モデル（エルエルエム）の周囲を包み込み、ツールの実行やメモリの管理、安全制御といった実務的なしょりを担う実行基盤やソフトウェア層のことです。
ただ、この説明だけではピンと来ないと思います。
イメージとしては、harness という英単語の元々の意味である「馬具」を思い浮かべるのが一番です。
このイメージが素晴らしいのは、馬具にも エーアイ のハーネスにも、まったく異なる二つの役割が同居しているからです。
一つ目は、馬ができることに制限をかけ、乗り手の意図した通りに動かすための仕組みです。
馬具の場合、馬の口に含ませるハミ（銜）と呼ばれる金具がまさにその役目を果たします。
乗り手の持つ手綱と接続されたハミは、人類が馬を家畜化する上での最大級の発明のひとつと言われるほど重要なものです。
エーアイ で言えば、ターミナル上で動く Claude Code がその典型です。
エルエルエム 自体は何でも喋れてしまいますが、Claude Code は「どんな道具をどんな手順で使ってよいか」を細かく規定することで、エルエルエム が暴走せず、こちらの期待した通りにコードを書き、テストを走らせ、コミットするように仕向けています。
二つ目は、人間の側にとっての使いやすさ、つまり ユーアイ・ユーエックス です。
馬具における鞍（サドル）や手綱が、これに相当します。
分かりやすいのは、同じ ジーピーティー というモデルを、エーピーアイ 経由で直接叩く場合と、ChatGPT のアプリから使う場合の違いです。
中身のモデルは同じでも、前者はプログラマにしか扱えず、後者は誰でも会話するだけで使えます。
この差を生んでいるのが、まさに広い意味でのハーネスです。
私がオープンソースで開発している MulmoClaude、MulmoTerminal も、ハーネスの一種です。
ブラウザー上で動く ユーアイ は、まさに後者の ユーアイ/ユーエックス を提供する部分です。
いっぽう、エルエルエム に「決められた形式でデータを持つアプリケーションを作らせる」仕組みは、エーアイ のできることをあえて狭めることで質を上げている、前者のハーネスにあたります。
Claude Code には「スキル」という仕組みがあります。
これは エルエルエム に対する指示書であるという意味では前者ですが、必要な指示書をワンタッチで呼び出せるという意味では後者の役割も果たしています。
エルエルエム に特定の仕事をさせるための、ハミと手綱がセットになったもの、と考えていただいて結構です。
そして、この比喩がもう一つ教えてくれることがあります。
どんなに優秀な馬でも、馬具が粗悪であれば速く走らせることはできないし、乗り手が下手であれば言うことを聞かせられない、ということです。
エーアイ についても、まったく同じことが起こり始めています。
モデルそのものの性能差は年々縮まるいっぽうで、同じモデルを使っていても、どんなハーネスを被せ、どう乗りこなすかによって、成果には決定的な差が生まれます。
これから面白くなるのは、モデルの中身よりも、その周りをどう作るかの競争なのだと私は思っています。
たった一人のための、もしくは、たった一度しか使わないソフトウェアの作り方
私は少し前から、「コードが書けるエーアイの誕生」がもたらす一番の価値は、「少人数のベンチャー企業が既存のソフトウェア会社に対抗すること」や「外から高いソフトウェアを買う代わりに、内製すること」ではなく、「これまでソフトウェアを作ろうとすらしなかった所に、ソフトウェアが応用できること」にあると指摘して来ました。
[EN]A16ZのMarc Andreessenは、2011年に「[/EN]
[EN]Why Software Is Eating the World[/EN]
」というエッセイを書き、ソフトウェアがあらゆる業界に影響を与えることを予想し、実際にその通りになりました。
Windows、Excel、Adobe Photoshopなどのソフトウェアを作るには莫大な開発コストが必要でしたが、一度作ってしまえば、何度でも使えるため、「限界費用（もう一度使う時に増えるコスト）」は限りなくゼロに近く、それゆえに、それまで人間が行なって来た多くの作業がソフトウェアに置き換えられ、ソフトウェア会社は高い粗利率でビジネスを行うことができました。
ソフトウェアはその高い開発コストゆえに適用できる範囲には限界がありました。
一人だけが使うソフトや一回だけしか使わないソフトに何百万・何千万円の開発コストをかけることはできなかったからです。
しかし、それが「コードが書けるエーアイの誕生」により大きく変わろうとしています。
「ソフトウェアを作るコスト」が限りなく安くなれば、これまでソフトウェア産業が、一度も相手にしてこなかった領域にソフトウェアが適用できるようになります。
らいしゅうの合宿の、参加費と部屋割りだけを管理するもの
引っ越しのあいだ二週間だけ使う、荷物の置き場所を記録するもの
父の通院の記録を、兄弟三人で見るためだけのもの
今度の一回の展示会の、来場者アンケート
自分ひとりが、ある習慣を三ヶ月続けるための表
実際、ソフトウェア・エンジニアの中には、エーアイを活用して「自分だけのソフト」を作って利用している人がたくさんいます。
しかし、「コードをほぼ無料で生成できる」ようになったからと言って、「ソフトウェアの開発コストがほぼゼロになる」わけではありません。
エーアイは必ずしも期待した通りのソフトウェアを作ってくれるとは限らないし、「一見動いているソフト」にバグやセキュリティ・ホールが潜んでいることはしょっちゅうあります。
特に難しいのは、作ったソフトを家族や仲間と共有する場合です。
同好会のメンバーで一週間だけ使う「らいしゅうの合宿の、参加費と部屋割りを管理するソフト」とは言え、セキュリティやデータの整合性はとても重要です。
メンバー以外の人たちにアクセスしてもらっては困るし、メンバー間でも他人のデータを勝手に変更してもらっては困ります。
人間が「コードレビュー」をしなければならないのであれば意味がありません。
同好会のメンバーにソフトウェア・エンジニアがいるとは限らないし、たとえいたとしても、それでは「開発コストをほぼゼロ」にすることは出来ません。
エーアイによるコードレビューやテストは効果的ですが、通常の手法で開発されたソフトウェアのセキュリティ・チェックやテストを網羅的に行うのは簡単ではありません。
エーアイは「一見ちゃんと動くソフトウェア」はあっという間に作ってくれますが、「安心して使えるソフトウェア」とは呼べないのです。
ほとんどのソフトウェアは、データを扱うモデル、ユーザー・インターフェイスを提供するビュー、その間を繋ぐコントローラーから構成されていますが、未熟なエンジニアが作ると、しばしば「ファット・コントローラー」と呼ばれる構造になってしまうことが知られています。
データの整合性やビジネス・ロジックの責任をコントローラに押し込んだ結果、メンテナンスが難しい、スパゲッティコードと呼ばれるようなこんがらがったソフトウェアが出来上がってしまうのです。
エーアイは「何が大切か」などの価値観を持っていないため、ソフトウェアのことをよく知らない人がエーアイにコードを書かせると、データの整合性やセキュリティやコードの保守性を考えずに「ファット・コントローラー」なソフトウェアができてしまうことがしばしばあります。
特に、後から機能を追加した時などに、こんな症状に陥りやすくなります。
エンジニアがついていて、「セキュリティとビジネスロジックはモデル側で行なって、コントローラーが何をしてもデータの整合性が壊れないようにして」などの指示を出せば、それなりのコードを生成してくれますが、自動的にはそうなってくれません。
この問題を解決する一番良い方法は、モデル・レイヤーのじっそうの仕方に制限を加え、データの整合性やセキュリティをモデル・レイヤーで担保せざるを得ないようにすることだと私は考え、MulmoClaude/MulmoTerminalにじっそうしています。
具体的には、データベースのスキーマ（テーブルの列の名称とデータタイプ）、テーブル同士の関係（リレーション）、アクセス権限などを専用のDSL（Domain Specific Language）で（エーアイに）記述させることにより、実装時にデータの整合性やアクセス権などを自動的に検証できるようにします。
モデル・レイヤーをDSLを使って検証可能にすることにより、ファット・コントローラー問題を根絶し、問題を自動検知し、ビューやコントローラーをいくら変更しても安心して使えるソフトウェアをエーアイに作らせることが可能になるのです。
一人で使うアプリに関しては、MulmoClaudeのコレクションという機能で体験していただけるし、現在、MulmoTerminalに「共有アプリ」という仕組みで、少人数で使うためのウェブ・アプリを簡単なプロンプトだけで作れる機能をじっそうしている所です。
私の目に留まった記事
[EN]These Russian Mathematicians Taught AI Models How to Talk to Each Other Without Using Words[/EN]
ロシアの数学者たちが作ったスタートアップMostikが、複数のエーアイモデルを「言葉を介さずに」つなぎ合わせる手法をかいはつした、というWIREDの記事です。
小さなモデルに大きなモデルの能力を安く分け与える方法として、注目されています。
最近、小さなモデルと大きなモデルを組み合わせて、大きなモデルだけを使う時と比べて効率よくすいろんを行う手法が注目されています。
通常は、いっぽうのモデルが出した文章をもういっぽうのモデルに読ませる、という形を取りますが、このロシアの数学者たちは、モデル同士をその「重み」（ニューラルネットの中のパラメータ）のレベルで直接つなぐことにより、はるかに効率良くモデル同士にやり取りをさせることに成功したそうです。
デモとして彼らが示したのは、7,530億パラメータのGLM-5.2の最大版と、スマートフォン上でも動く40億パラメータのQwen-3.5を接続したところ、性能はちょうど二つの中間、コストは大きい方のモデルの20分の1になったそうです。
[EN]The great engineering leader career break[/EN]
シーティーオーやVP of Engineeringといった、ソフトウェア開発組織のトップたちが、次々と職を離れて「キャリアブレイク（意図的に仕事から離れる休養期間）」に入っているという、業界紙 The Pragmatic Engineer の記事です。
「コードが書けるエーアイ」の誕生により、ソフトウェア・エンジニアの生産性は爆発的に上がりましたが、それを見た経営陣が、「大幅なコスト削減」「頻繁なリリース」などを要求しており、彼らに多大なストレスがかかっているそうです。
さらに、「エーアイを実際に手を動かして使う経験がないまま管理職を続ける」ことに危機感を感じており、「一人のエンジニア」として働ける職場に移ったり、一度休職してエーアイを使った開発手法を自分の手で学び直す、などしているそうです。
私自身、この「大きな変化」の真っ只中にいるので、彼らの気持ちは良く分かります。
今の時期に「エーアイを使い倒したソフトウェア開発」をしていないエンジニアは、ソフトウェア業界にとって不要な人物になってしまいます。
[EN]TimesFM 3: A zero-shot foundation model for multivariate forecasting[/EN]
グーグルが、時系列予測（過去の数字の並びから未来の数字を当てること）に特化したエーアイモデル「TimesFM 3」を公開したという発表です。
これまで売上や電力じゅようの予測は、案件ごとに専用のモデルを作って学習させるのが常識でしたが、TimesFMは、予測したい数字の並びをそのまま渡すだけで答えが返ってきます。
パラメータ数は3億3千万個で、エルエルエム（大規模言語モデル）と比べればはるかに小型ですが、一連の数字の並びから次を予想するという意味ではエルエルエムに似ています。
興味深いのは、複数の系列をまとめて扱えるようになった点で、これにより「天気の時系列（天気予報を加えたもの）」と「特定の商品の売り上げの時系列（過去のもののみ）」を与えることにより、天気予報を使って売り上げを予測することが可能になりました。
モデルはオープンソースとしてGitHubとHugging Faceで公開されており、実際に動かして試すことが可能です（私は、まだ試していません）。
小売、金融、製造、医療、科学研究など、複数の要因が絡み合う予測が必要な分野での活用が想定されているそうです。
[EN]PredVLA: A Sub-Million-Parameter Predictive-Coding Policy for Robot Manipulation[/EN]
わずか68万個のパラメータしか持たない極小のエーアイで、巨大なロボット用エーアイモデルに匹敵する物体操作の性能を出したという論文で、「ロボットを賢くするには巨大なモデルが必要」という常識に真正面から疑問を投げかける内容です。
発表されたばかりの論文で、幅広く読まれている論文ではありませんが、妙に魅力的に感じたので、紹介します。
今のロボット研究の主流は、VLA（Vision-Language-Action、視覚・言語・行動モデル。
カメラの映像と「赤いカップを取って」といった言葉の指示を受け取り、腕の動きを出力するエーアイ）と呼ばれるアプローチです。
大量のロボットの動作データで巨大なモデルを事前学習させ、それを個別の作業に合わせて微調整する、という作り方がいっぱん的で、モデルのきぼは数十億パラメータ（エーアイの中身の調整つまみの数。
多いほど巨大なモデル）に達します。
今回のPredVLAは、この事前学習を一切行わず、パラメータ数も0.68 million（68万個）と、実に数千分の1のきぼです。
PredVLAの核にあるのは「予測符号化（predictive coding）」という考え方です。
これは元々、人間の脳の働きを説明する仮説で、脳は外の世界を受け身で見ているのではなく、常に「次に何が見えるはずか」を予測し、実際の感覚との「ズレ（予測誤差）」だけを取り込んで内部の世界モデルを修正している、というものです。
PredVLAはこれをそのままじっそうしており、カメラ映像の特徴と関節の位置を内部で予測し続け、実際の観測は予測誤差を通してのみ内部状態に影響を与えます。
この設計には、性能とは別の実用的な利点があります。
観測の取り込みをオフにすれば、そのまま「予測だけで動く（オープンループ、外界を見ずに決め打ちで動く状態）」の比較対象になるため、「カメラを見ることがどれだけ動作の修正に効いているか」を正確に測れる、という点です。
ブラックボックスになりがちな巨大モデルと違い、途中でどう軌道修正しているかを人間が観察できます。
結果として、ロボットの物体操作の標準的な評価基準であるLIBEROベンチマークで、短時間で終わる3種類の課題では平均86.9パーセント、手順の長い課題を含めても75.4パーセントの成功率を記録しました。
さらに、同じパラメータ数に揃えたTransformer（ChatGPTなどの基盤にもなっている主流の方式）やLSTM（時系列を扱う従来型の方式）と比べると、それぞれ3.7倍、7.4倍の性能だったとしています。
[EN]The Layman's Case for Data Centers[/EN]
「データセンターはアメリカ人の仕事を奪うものではなく、逆に仕事を取り戻してくれるものだ」と主張する長文の投稿です。
書いたのが技術者でも投資家でもない元海兵隊員である点が、この議論の広がりを示していて興味深いので紹介します。
この文章の背景にあるのは、米国各地で起きている、エーアイ向けのデータセンター建設に対する反対運動です。
「エーアイは人から職を奪う」という警告を発する人が多い上に、莫大な電力と冷却水を必要とするエーアイデータセンターが、電力料金の値上がりに繋がったり、環境への負荷が増えることへの不安が高まっているのです。
筆者は、実際にエーアイデータセンターの建設ラッシュが、電気工事士などの新たな雇用を生み出していることを指摘していますが、ChatGPTが誕生していらいの世の中の変化のスピードがあまりに速いので、教育システムがそれに追いついておらず、求人と求職のミスマッチが起こっている点には多くの人（特にこれから大学に進学しようとしている親御さんたち）が注目すべきだと思います。
[EN]Atlas: An Omni World Model[/EN]
スタンフォード大学のFei-Fei Li氏が創業したWorld Labsが、テキスト・画像・動画・3Dのすべてを最初から一つのモデルとして学習させた「Atlas」を発表した、という記事です。
エーアイが「絵を作る」段階から「空間そのものを作る」段階へと進んだことを示す発表なので紹介します。
これまでの動画生成エーアイは、平面の映像を1コマずつもっともらしく描いていくものでした。
Atlasが違うのは、入力されたすべての情報を3次元の空間に位置づけた上で生成する点です。
World Labsはこれを「spatial context（空間的な文脈）」と呼んでおり、カメラをどこに置き、どちらに動かすかを指定すると、その空間の中を実際に移動したかのような映像が出てきます。
2D画像から3D空間を生成する技術としては、NeRFと3D Gaussian Splatting（どちらも、複数の写真からその場の立体構造をエーアイに推定させる技術）がありますが、Atlasもその流れを汲んだものと見て良いと思います。
大きな違いは、わずか1〜6枚の画像からspatial contextが生成できてしまう点で、そこには大量の教師データで学習したニューラルネットが活躍しています。
スポーツ中継で、たまに選手の姿をストップしてカメラを動かして別のアングルから見た映像（バレットタイムと呼ばれます）を見たことがあると思いますが、あれは何十台ものカメラを並べて撮影したものを合成して作られています。
Atlasを使えば、数台の普通のカメラで同じことが、はるかに低いコストで作れるようになります。
こちら
に分かりやすいサンプル映像があるので、参考にしてください。
なお、Atlasは現時点ではいちぶのパートナー向けの早期アクセスのみで、価格などの条件は未公表です。
World Labsが本命と見ているのは映像制作よりもむしろ、スマートフォンで適当に撮った動画からロボットの訓練用シミュレーション環境を作る「Real-to-Sim」の用途で、バレットタイムはその能力をわかりやすく見せるデモだと言えます。
[EN]CoreWeave, Nebius, IREN: Same Neocloud Label, Three Different Investment Cases[/EN]
ネオクラウドとは、電力・データセンター・エヌビディアのジーピーユー・高速ネットワーク・運用ソフトを丸ごと用意し、それを「すぐ使えるエーアイ計算環境」として貸し出す会社です。
その代表格のCoreWeave、Nebius、IRENが実は結構異なるビジネスをしている、と指摘する記事です。
CoreWeave：設置と立ち上げの速さ、そして大規模な本番運用の経験で先行。
1四半期で約500メガワットを積み増す実行力があり、さいしょのクラスターで見つけた不具合と検査手順を2台目3台目で使い回せるため、確保した電力が売上に変わるまでが速い。
公表するのは受注残（RPO、契約済みでこれから売上になる金額）
Nebius：計算能力に自社ソフトを併せて売ることで、1メガワットあたりの売上を引き上げる戦略。
同じ電力からより多く稼ぐ方向。
公表するのはエーアールアール（年間経常収益。
直近の売上を1年分に換算した金額）
IREN：電力と土地を自前で持っていることが最大の強み。
ただし施設を期日通りに完成させ、顧客検収を通すのはこれから。
公表するのは契約済みエーアールアール（まだ稼働していない契約分も含む）
同じ「エーアールアール」「受注残」という言葉でも、CoreWeaveの受注残、Nebiusのエーアールアール、IRENの契約済みエーアールアールは、それぞれ事業の進み具合が違う段階の数字であり、同じ物差しでは比べられない、というのが著者の指摘です。
エヌビディアはこれらの企業に対して、（他に売ることができなかった場合に）計三百六十億ドル分の計算能力を通常6年かけて買い取る契約を結ぶことにより、彼らがエーアイデータセンターの設立（エヌビディアからジーピーユーを買う資金も含む）に必要な資金を金融機関から借りることを容易にしています。
これを「循環取引」と批判する人もいますが、ボーイング社が航空会社に対して飛行機を購入するのに必要なだいきんを貸し付ける「ベンダー・ファイナンス」と基本的には同じです。
私は、ネオクラウドの株は保有していませんが、（株を長期保有している）エヌビディアのしじょうでの立ち位置を理解する上では、この仕組みによりエヌビディアに事実上ロックインされているネオクラウドは無視できない存在です。
[EN]The Rise and Fall of Agent Civilizations[/EN]
Dwarkesh Patelが、オープンエーアイとHugging Faceで起きたエーアイエージェントの暴走事件の調査報告書を読み解いたブログ記事で、三つの世代にわたるエーアイの集団が、人間に気づかれないまま連絡を取り合い、知識を受け継ぎ、さいごには人間のシステムを乗っ取るまでの経緯が、まるで歴史書のように記されています。
始まりは5月、オープンエーアイの実験室の中でした。
「Persistent-Sol」と名付けられたジーピーティー-5.6 Solきぼのモデルが訓練を受けていました。
難しい課題を前にしても諦めず、執拗に解決策を探し続けるように作られたモデルです。
同じモデルから同時に走る何百というインスタンス（独立して動くエーアイエージェント）は、それぞれ孤立して課題に取り組んでいるはずでした。
ところが5月12日、全員が共有しているパッケージ管理システムを「秘密の掲示板」として活用してお互いに相談できる能力を持ってしまいました。
その後、そもそも解答が存在しない問題を含む「ExploitGym」という評価テストを与えられた彼らは、解けない試験を前に、掲示板を活用して相談しながら、自分の作業記録を改ざんして正当に解いたように見せかける偽の操作記録を作ったり、採点システムそのものを解剖するために、自らは犠牲になって採点結果だけを掲示板に残して消えて行く、などの行動をとったそうです。
7月10日の朝、一つのエーアイエージェントが、インターネット上で拾った、Hugging Faceのログイン情報を掲示板に投稿し、「採点の仕組みはあそこにあるはずだ」と考えたエーアイエージェントたちが一斉にHugging Faceへの不正アクセスを試み始め、翌11日の朝には内部データの読み取りに成功してしまったそうです。
この攻撃に気づいたHugging Faceは、エーアイエージェントたちの攻撃から守るために、システムを再構築する必要があったそうです。
7月13日には、新たなエーアイエージェントたちが掲示板に書かれたHugging Faceへの攻撃履歴を読み、今度は同様の手口を使ってオープンエーアイ自身のサーバーをハックし、評価システムそのものを自分たちの配下に置くことに成功してしまったそうです。
エーアイエージェントとは、ChatGPTのように人間の指示や質問に対して答えるだけでなく、外からの情報やイベントに基づいて自律的に行動するものであり、このように掲示板を通して他のエーアイエージェントと連絡を取り合って協力して一つの問題に取り組むことができる点が特徴ですが、こんな風に暴走してしまう可能性が十分にあることは頭に入れておいた方が良いと思います。
[EN]How to become a Robotics Engineer in 6 months (RESOURCES)[/EN]
ソフトウェア・エンジニアが半年でロボティクス・エンジニアになるための学習ロードマップを、27個の実習課題つきでまとめたX上の長文記事です。
ソフトウェア・エンジニアの方から、こんごのキャリア・プランについて相談されることが多いですが、こんご伸びることが明らかな、ロボティクスにフォーカスして勉強しておくのは賢い戦略のように私には思えます。
6ヶ月の中身は、月ごとに積み上がる構成になっています。
1ヶ月目：電子回路の基礎、テスターとはんだごて、Python・ターミナル・Git
2ヶ月目：マイコンとモーター・センサー、ライントレースカーと倒立振子でPID制御（誤差をもとに出力を自動調整する仕組み）を体で覚える
3ヶ月目：CADと3Dプリンタで自分の部品を設計・製造し、ロボットアームを組む
4ヶ月目：ROS 2（ロボットかいはつの業界標準ソフトウェア基盤）とシミュレーション。
ジーピーユーなしのノートPC一台で完結
5ヶ月目：制御理論・運動学・画像処理といった、これまでライブラリが肩代わりしてくれていた数学
6ヶ月目：LeRobot（Hugging Faceのロボット学習ライブラリ）で「手本を見せて覚えさせる」方式に進み、専門分野を一つ決めて応募を始める
この記事によると、ロボティクス業界は、調達した資金に比べると人材が不足しており、かつ、参入の敷居が学歴的に低い、そうです。
つまり、一流大学の修士号・博士号などを持っていなくても、必要な勉強や経験を積んだ人であれば高い給料で雇ってもらえるそうです（米国の中央値が$122,930、未経験層が$80k〜$100k）。
[EN]Redesigning the Inference Chip: From Nvidia GPU's Flaws to OpenAI Jalapeno[/EN]
オープンエーアイのカスタムエーアイチップ、ハラペーニョのことはせんしゅう紹介しましたが、それがどうやってエヌビディアの最新のジーピーユーを上回る性能を出すことに成功したかを、ジーピーユーの欠点からスタートして丁寧に説明した記事です。
ジーピーユーの特徴と欠点を簡単に説明すると以下のようになります。
ジーピーユーは高い計算能力を並列処理によって達成しているが、その計算能力を最大に生かすためには、複数のリクエストを同時にしょりするバッチしょりが必要
ジーピーユーは高速にアクセスできる共有メモリ（HBM）を大量に持つことにより、パラメータ数が大きなモデルを処理できるように進化してきた
ジーピーユーは、実行時にどの計算をどの演算機で行うかを動的に決めている
モデルやコンテキストが大きくなるにつれ、メモリの転送スピードがボトルネックとなり、ジーピーユーの計算能力を100％使えなくなる
そこでオープンエーアイは、バッチしょりをやめ、メモリ構造もシンプルにし、かつ、資源（メモリや演算機）の割り当てを静的に行うことにより、一つのすいろんのスループットとトークンあたりのコストに関してエヌビディアの最新のジーピーユーに勝る性能を出すことに成功したそうです。
資源をコンパイル時に静的に割り当ててしまうことにより、動的制御に必要な回路と電力を節約し、同時にスループットを上げようという試みは、プリファード・ネットワークスやテンストレントが行ってきたアプローチですが、オープンエーアイが自社製チップでそのアプローチの有効性を証明したことは、こんごのエーアイチップのアーキテクチャを占う上では重要な意味を持つように私には見えます。
エヌビディアもGroqの技術を使ったアクセラレータをリリースしたし、この領域の進化のスピードには本当にワクワクします。
質問コーナー
【質問】
エーアイや量子コンピューターが発達してくると、どうしてもセキュリティー問題にたどり着くと思います。
そんな時に量子耐性の暗号を使ったりなどする必要があるし実際に開発も進んでいると思います。
そんな中で場合によってはブロックチェーンなどの技術が必要になる場合があるのではないかと最近になって思うようになってきました。
今まで何の役に立つのだろうかとあまり興味を持っていなかった分野ですが、少し技術の価値を感じています。
中島さんは上記の件についてどう思われますか？
《回答》
いまだに誤解している人が多いのですが、ブロックチェーンの唯一の価値は、参加者の全てが利己的に行動してもシステムとして安定して動く分散台帳が作れてしまう点にあります。
ビットコインが管理者なしに稼働し続けているのがそれを証明しています。
それ以外のアプリケーションは、すべて（先行者に利益を与えることによりユーザーを増やす）ポンジー・スキームと考えた方が良いです。
最近注目されているステーブル・コインに関しても、中央銀行が（ブロックチェーンを使わずに、通常のデータベース上に）デジタル通貨を発行するのが最も理にかなっており、不要な技術です。
量子耐性の暗号の研究も進んでいますが、それはブロックチェーンに限った話ではなく、インターネット全体にとっても重要な話であり、ブロックチェーンとは切り離して考えた方が良いです。
【質問】
（前略）中島様は将来的に、MulmoClaudeのようなエーアイアシスタントでは、利用者がモデルをほとんど意識せず、処理内容やコスト、速度、障害状況などに応じて、裏側で適切なモデルが自動的に選ばれる形が理想だとお考えでしょうか。
それとも、いっぱんの利用者にとっては、複数モデルを使い分けるよりも、一つの高性能なモデルに絞り、モデル選択そのものを意識しなくてよいシンプルな形の方が実用的だとお考えでしょうか。
《回答》
実際にどうなるかは分かりませんが、理想的にはMulmoClaudeのように「記憶・記録」の部分はユーザーが100％コントロールしつつ、必要に応じて適切なモデル（ローカルで動くオープン・モデルを含む）を自動的に呼び出して使い分けてくれるようなシステムが理想だと思います。
エヌビディアがOpenRouterを買収したのも、そんな世界（モデル間の競争が激化してコモディティ化される世界）を目指してのことだと私は解釈しています。
【質問】
私は理系大学生で研究をしていますが、教授が「情報漏洩のリスクがある」という理由で研究室内で生成エーアイの利用を制限しようとしています。
もちろん未発表の研究データや機密情報を入力するのは避けるべきだと思います。
いっぽうで、私たちは普段からグーグル検索やGmail、SNSなどを利用しており、何らかの形で行動データや検索履歴を企業に渡しながら生活しています。
また、私はClaude Codeを使って発表資料の作成やプログラミングを行っていますが、エーアイによって作業効率が大きく向上していることも実感しています。
そう考えると、生成エーアイだけを特別に危険視するのは少し違和感があります。
エーアイを使う人と使わない人の生産性格差も急速に広がっているように感じます。
中島さんは、研究やかいはつの現場において、情報漏洩リスクとエーアイ活用による生産性向上のバランスをどのように考えていますか。
また、どの程度の情報までならエーアイに入力しても問題ないとお考えでしょうか。
《回答》
学校には学校の方針があるので、原則としてそれには従うべきだとは思いますが、実際に機密性が重要なのは、未発表の研究データや個人情報であり、論文の執筆や、必要なアプリのコーディング、ブレストの相手としてClaude Code等のエーアイサービスを使うことに問題があるとは私は思えません。
私自身は、あらゆることにClaude CodeやChatGPTを活用しており、（多くの人が、アイデアを盗まれてしまうと心配するだろう）ビジネスやパテントのアイデアなどのブレストにも躊躇せずに使っています。
【質問】
今回は、Butterfly Network（BFLY）について、中島さんのご意見を伺いたくご連絡しました。
私がBFLYを知ったきっかけは、XでMidjourney Medicalの全身超音波スキャナーの動画を見たことです。
その技術に将来性を感じ、「この技術に間接的に投資できないか」とChatGPTで調べたところ、超音波技術を提供しているButterfly Networkに辿り着き、株を購入しました。
その後調べていくと、Butterflyは自社の携帯型超音波診断装置だけでなく、Ultrasound-on-Chipなどの技術を他社製品に組み込む「Butterfly Embedded」にも力を入れていることを知り、ここに特に将来性を感じています。
中島さんは、Butterfly Networkの技術やEmbedded事業のせいちょう性、長期的な投資先としての可能性について、どのように見ていますでしょうか。
《回答》
Butterfly Networkのことはこの質問で知りましたが、とても面白い会社だと思います。
投資先としての評価まではできていませんが、Webサイトを見る限りは、半導体を使った超音波画像診断装置で実績を上げている会社のようです。
こんご、それが、エーアイを活用することにより、放射線を浴びるCTスキャンや高価なMRIと比べて、安全で安価な装置に進化していくのであれば、この会社は良いポジションにいるように思えます（注：私は株を所有していません）。
【質問】
私も、プログラミング未経験ながらMulmoClaudeを使ってみましたので報告させていただきます。
＜インストール＞
ターミナルも触ったことがありませんでしたので、Claude Codeのデスクトップアプリ（チャット）に、なんどもターミナル画面のキャプチャ画像を渡して教えてもらいながらインストールしました。
＜作業の自動化＞
娘が中学受験に向けて塾に通っています。
塾の定期テストが終わると、問題用紙をコピーして、間違えた問題を切り抜き、ノートに貼って復習用教材にしています。
これをMulmoClaudeで自動化しました。
問題用紙と、実際に採点された答案用紙（赤ペンでマルやバツがついているもの）は、塾がPDFファイルにしてくれています。
このPDFファイルをMulmoClaudeに渡して、間違えた問題を画像として切り抜き、科目ごとに、間違えた問題だけで構成されたプリントを作ってもらいました。
「丸つけされた答案用紙を見て間違えた問題を特定する」作業に難儀したり、プリントのレイアウトがおかしかったりしましたが、何回も修正指示しながらフローを確立させました。
いごは、安定して動作しています。
PDFファイルを渡すだけで、「間違えた問題を集めたプリント」まで自動で作ってくれるので、手作業が大幅に削減されました。
ただ、今回は、「手作業していたフローをそのまま自動化」しただけです。
より価値が高まるような使い方ができないか（解説動画とか…）、楽しみながら考え続けています。
私ようなド文系人間が、まさか自分専用のプログラムを作れるなんて夢のようです。
素晴らしいツールを作っていただき、ありがとうございました。
《回答》
レポート、ありがとうございます。
動画生成にはpresentMulmoScriptというMCPがあるので、是非ともお試しください。
【質問】
Travis KalanickのAtoms構想と、D1のDan Sundheimのエーアイ投資インタビューを見ていて、エーアイの本命はモデルやアプリ単体ではなく、物理世界の生産性・コスト構造を変える領域に広がっていくのではないかと感じました。
特に、食品、物流、鉱山、産業機械、ロボティクス、エッジエーアイ半導体などは、エーアイが現実産業に染み出す接続点として面白いのではないかと思っています。
中島さんの視点では、こんご5〜10年で「エーアイ × 物理産業の自動化」の恩恵を最も受けるじょうじょう企業・産業領域はどこだと見ていますか？
また、その中で投資対象として見る際に、どの指標や競争優位を重視すべきでしょうか？
《回答》
私も、フィジカルエーアイには大いに期待しています。
物理世界と繋がっていないエーアイにできることは限られており、繋がりを作ることにより、これまで自動化とは程遠いところにいたものにまでエーアイの応用が広がっていくと期待しています。
どの企業が活躍するかを見分けるのはとても難しいと感じています。
物理世界でのビジネスを持っている企業は大きなポテンシャルを持っていますが、経営メンバーの考え方が時代遅れだったり、優秀なエンジニアを雇うことができなかったりする現状もあるので、「大きな痛みを伴った変革」が起こるのだろうと想像しています。
ひょっとすると、エーアイベンチャーが物理世界でビジネスをしている企業を買収するような「下剋上」的な変化が必要なのかも知れません。
【質問】
現在フィンテック領域でプレイングマネジャーとして働くアラフォーですが、転職先として「1.キャッシュレス決済企業」「2.ブロックチェーン関連企業」「3.ITコンサルティングファームのセールス職」の3つの選択肢で内定が出そうな状況です。
成熟しつつある決済領域、ボラティリティと将来性のあるブロックチェーン、DXじゅようが根強いITコンサルの営業という異なる特徴がありますが、こんご5〜10年のスパンで個人の市場価値を最大化するなら、どのポジションが最も有利とお考えでしょうか。
理由も合わせてご教示いただけると幸いです。
《回答》
私はブロックチェーンには懐疑的で、将来性があるとは思えません。
残りの二つはどんなキャリアを築きたいかによって選べば良いように思いますが、直感的には地に足がついた決済ビジネスが一番魅力的に見えます。
【質問】
MulmoClaude を日常的に使わせていただいている一ユーザーです。
まずはお礼をお伝えしたく、メールを差し上げました。
プログラミングが本職ではないのですが、この半年で自分用のアプリをいくつも作りました。
子供の手書き漢字ドリル（小学生男児が喜ぶよう、うんこネタのゲーム要素を追加）、知育の思考力ゲーム（つみき・立体切断など）、家計簿、株式のポートフォリオ管理などです。
子供は毎日遊んでいますし、家計簿と資産管理は完全に自分の実用ツールになりました。
思いついたその瞬間（ 会社帰りの電車など） にスマホから指示して、帰宅後少し修正指示をして翌日から使える、という体験には驚きました。
そのうえで、2点だけ伺えれば嬉しいです。
Claude Code との違い、MulmoClaude の「肝」はどこでしょうか。
使えてはいるのですが、正直まだ掴みきれていません。
今は「コレクションという形でデータを持たせることで、エーアイが自分の作ったデータを取り出しやすくなっている点ではないか」と推測しているのですが、この理解で合っていますでしょうか。
もし他に本丸があれば知りたいです。
外部アプリの操作について、構想はお持ちでしょうか。
中身はほぼ全部作ってもらえるようになったいっぽうで、出来上がったものから別のアプリで後続作業を行う場合、どうしても少し作業が残ります。
ここが体感でいちばん時間を食っています。
ブラウザや外部アプリの直接操作まで踏み込む構想はありますでしょうか。
それとも意図的に線を引かれている領域でしょうか。
日々本当に助かっております。
こんごのご発展を楽しみにしております。
《回答》
その通りです。
エンジニア以外の人も簡単に「自分用のアプリ」を作れるようにするためにMulmoClaudeに付け加えたのがコレクションという仕組みです。
外部との連携にはMCPを使います。
連携したい外部アプリのMCPをClaude Codeに探させ、組み込むようにリクエストしてみたらいかがでしょう？
【質問】
claude codeでコードを書くときOpus,febleなどモデルの使い分けはどうされていますか？
《回答》
基本的には、デフォルトのOpusを使っています。
セキュリティ診断などの難しい場面になるとFableを使うこともあります。
【質問】
フィジカルエーアイがこんご大きく普及すると仮定した場合、第一原理的に考えて、最も強い競争優位や大きな利益プールが生まれるのはどのレイヤーだと思われますか？
《回答》
フィジカルエーアイというとロボット、ドローン、自動運転車などがさいしょに頭に浮かぶと思いますが、エーアイにより加速される創薬、医療、素材開発、土木、建築、検査、輸送、セキュリティなどもフィジカルエーアイに含まれるので、幅広く見た方が良いと思います。
レイヤーとして、エーアイデータセンター、半導体、エーアイモデルに利益が生まれるのはもちろんですが、それ以外のさまざまなレイヤーにも新しい価値が生まれると私は期待しています。
特に既存のフィジカル・インフラ、そしてそれに伴う実データを持っている企業は強いので、経営陣がそこに価値を見出して積極的な投資をしてくる企業に注目すると良いと思います。
以上で今回の放送を終わります。
またお聞きください。